good afternoon my name is Rio Sanchez
and we are both members of the
blockchain team of what for research on
America and we're going to show you the
new additions to the blockchain
integration from work from language like
for example the new Mars launching yes
and I'm going to talk about the Oracle
progress we doing
okay so for those of you that are not
familiar with the topic let's start with
the question what is a blotchy so
there's really no standard definition
for a blocking we usually have to adapt
to the different architecture for each
block chain but just as a general idea a
blockchain is a decentralized or
distributed append-only later here in
the image below we can see that each of
these nodes represent this of these dots
represents a node in the network and
each of these nodes has a copy of the
blockchain and the way they agree on the
validity of this block chain is by a
consensus algorithm and also a common
architecture for a blockchain involves
making set of transactions then putting
those transactions inside of a block and
then linking each new block
cryptographically in a sequence or a
chain okay so how can we interact with a
blockchain using one from language here
we have some function some reading
functions and writing functions here a
blockchain data is used to get some
general information about a blockchain
blockchain block data is used to get the
information about a specific block in
the blockchain right so which block is a
set has a set of transactions inside and
we can look at the details of each
transaction using blockchain transaction
data and finally each section is usually
the exchange of currency between sender
and receiver addresses and we can look
at those addresses in more detail using
watching address data so if we want to
add information to the block we want to
add a transaction to the block we have
to use blockchain transaction to first
make to create a transaction object then
we have to sign that object using boxing
transaction sign and finally send it to
the blockchain using boxing transaction
submit so all of these functions work
for the Bitcoin and etherion blockchain
and we are not now adding support for
the arc blockchain as well so let's talk
a little bit about arc so arc is a
delegated proof of stake blockchain that
refers to for blockchain creation this
delegated proof of stake is the name of
the
consensus algorithm but the way it works
is that every address inside of the arc
watching can vote for a specific
delegate and there they're called that
delegate and by staking their balance so
the money they have and only the top 51
delegates are the ones that are allowed
to forge a new block so that word
forging is the equivalent to mining in
Bitcoin so they're the ones that are
have the the job to pack these
transactions inside of a block and then
add this block to the blockchain yes
here's the page for arc and now thanks
to the partnership between arc and war
from within this reading writing
functions to connect to the to the arc
maintenance and definite networks okay
so let's start interacting with arc by
creating a simple transaction in this
example I'm going to send some mark from
an existing address to a newly created
address so this could be like me getting
my personal information and starting to
send some marks to a friend of mine for
example and we can do this in these
three steps create sign and submit okay
so here I have this Neutron certain this
new address it would be the my recipient
address then I could import my personal
information that my personal keys here I
have a private key a public key of this
particular address right so this is an
already existing address in the arc but
I'll say this for later and I have to
make sure that this address has enough
balance to pay for the amount and the
fee so I can check that you seem quickly
using boxiong address data here and I
see that I have enough balance then I
just have to decide on a fee and an
amount that I want to use
I'll explain these quantities a little
bit later in more detail but for now I
just have to add all of this inside of
the blockchain transaction function so
here I have its association with a
blockchain base
sorry I specified the blockchain base
Ark here I'd add the recipient the fee
the amount and I could also add this
little message here with using this
bender field okay so now what I have is
a virtual transaction object it has a
summary of all of this information here
so next the sender address has to feel
sorry it has to sign this transaction
using blockchain transaction sign we
could hear the the object we just
created and the private key of that the
sender right so now this new object that
appears is already signed and has this
new properties sender public key and the
signature here that's important part so
these two steps creating and signing are
both down locally so we have not really
send the transaction to the blockchain
yet we do that with blockchain
transaction submit and if if everything
is if we did everything correctly we
should get this virtual transaction
object with the added field transaction
ID so this is our new transaction ID but
we have still have to wait for this
transaction to be picked up and added to
a new block and for that block to be
forged by a delegate in the case of arc
so usually the amount of time we have to
wait depends on the fee that we chose
but for now let's review all of this
information and some more details about
arc using the reading functions so first
with Bachchan data I hope you can see
that it's a little bit small in the data
set here sorry for that but we can get
some information like the latest block
ID in the blockchain we can get the
total number of blocks and the fee
statistics for each particular
transaction type so this is something
about arc arc has multiple transaction
types the one we just did and it's a
transfer transaction type which means
that we're just exchanging currency
between and one address and second
address they also have these these the
second signature transaction there
nay dressed to basically add a second
private key to their account so they can
have increased security you also have
this delegate registration so any
address could register as a delegate for
the the arc blockchain and then this
boat a transaction that allows an
address to vote for a particular
delegate so these are the ones were
supporting right now and if you see this
table here we can use this as a
reference for future transactions if we
want to to help us decide on a fee right
so that's why I chose this one and
because these are quantity supported in
Wolfram language we can easily convert
those to have them as US dollars for
example so that transaction cost me one
cent yeah oh yeah and this one our
katashi is just the name of the minimum
unit of currency in arc yeah and one arc
is the name of the main coin they use so
we're supporting all okay so now we can
review the the newly created transaction
so the fact that we can even see this
output here is because that instruction
is already part of the blockchain so if
everything worked out fine here we get a
summary of the transaction right the
sender the recipient this is the type
transfer type the amount the fee and
here's our little message that will
include something else that we can do
here is check on the block ID the block
ID so this is the block that where this
transaction is contained in the
blockchain so we can use blockchain
block data now with that ID to look at
our block right so here we have a lot of
information about the block for example
this generator field that I have here
has information about the delegate who
forged this block so this is their user
name their address and their public key
and because they they Forge the block
they get the reward that I talked about
plus the fees of all of the transactions
inside
then and well in this case is only my
transaction so here we can see the debt
under the forged field here we can see
the the reward this is like a study
reward for forging one blog and this is
the fee I use right so yes total of that
now I can look at the address that was
the recipient address here does the new
address to see the information and we
see that the balance shown here is the
amount that was transferred so this is
now the new balance that this address
has and and they could use future
transactions using this this amount of
money that they have and here we also
have their equivalents in u.s. dollars
and a list of all of the transactions in
this case only only this one right okay
and other thing we could do is compare
the old and the new balance of the
sender address so their existing address
that I have here I saved the dear old
balance I can get the new balance doing
the same thing once again specifying
here a sub property of the of the output
and compare that that new balance plus
the amount was the fees it was the the
old balance that I have so we could also
look using boxing address data
specifically at delegate this is the
delegate of forced our block and because
this is a delegate we get actually an
extended output here with more
information so important things for
example the the rank of this delegate is
39 so because he's inside of those top
51 he was able to forge this block here
we can see the amount of bolts they have
right we could see you seen the border
for field which delegate this address
border for so in this case obviously
they voted for themselves right yeah and
we could see the list of all the borders
all the addresses that that use that
both type transaction - both for this
delegate yes a lot of small section
addresses here
and we could also see and the
information about these delegates
revenue you seen that force field so
this is just a summary of that so yes
this just about sums up the the arc
integration for Wolfram language and our
progress in Oracle so so what is an
Oracle initially block chains were
developed to bribe just simple crypto
currency transactions into a
decentralized ledger and some of these
transactions allow certain condition in
order to be valid like the signature of
as the technology evolved block chains
that support turing-complete lounge
languages began to appear letting
developers to specify all kinds of
condition into the so-called smart
contracts but soon they realized that in
order to create browser applications
they would need data from the external
world and since warfarin WolframAlpha is
the largest computational engine in the
world used by various virtual assistants
like Sir Ian Alexa among others it just
seems natural to use warfarin alpha as
the main provider of computational facts
for small contracts so here's our
proposed architecture for the Oracle
there are two main components in this
architecture the first one is the
warfarin oracle contract that lives
inside a blockchain and the other one is
the warfarin compute nodes on the
outside a contract that wants to query
alpha would internally call our warrant
oracle contracts that will trigger an
event with all the query parameters and
then the compute node will listen to the
event say call the query parameters make
a request to alpha and finally submit a
transaction in order to deliver the data
the user contract has requested
currently we're testing this
architecture on the
the intestinal network of the Turin
protocol it uses natural language to
interact with the Oracle so there is no
need for the developer to handle messy
and poorly documented api's there are
mainly two ways to interact with the
Oracle a dual developer might just copy
and paste a piece of solidity function
code to their smart contract and use it
but it is also possible to deploy a
contract and use it interact with a
contract using our various function
blockchain functions we have developed
in the world front language so let's
take a look at the Oracle here's the
front end of our Oracle we have an input
box and we have a couple of options
right now like like I just said we are
supporting only solidity for aetherium
but we are doing some progress in
integrating other block blockchain soon
so let's make a simple query like and
sorry for example if I want to see I'm
not used to using Mac's for example if
we want to know how much is Anissa in
u.s. dollars let's look what the Oracle
gives us so it gives us a password from
language expression and the result of
the query the developer by which by
looking the result he can verify that
this query is actually what he was
looking for below we have a piece of
solidity function that he can just paste
on a copy and paste in his contract and
interact with alpha now let's make a
little bit more complicated query like
if we want to know the temperature in
Boston
we can see here that the disambiguation
is handle as well so if the developer
meant another city for example in
Georgia you just have to click it in the
drop down menu and it will take us to
the right query again we have the the
past foreign language expression the
result and the solidity function yeah oh
yeah that is because I made a mistake
but in any case it works only internally
right now so I prefer not to refresh the
page so we're website now if we change
to the contra option let's make a little
bit another query for example we want to
get a random integer between 10 and 50
in this case in the contract we have
again path Werfel language expression
the result but this time we have a whole
contract of the lady that we have that
we can deploy and run and I'm getting
I'm running out of time so let's just
get back to the notebook so if you take
the contract template you could deploy
it using our blockchain functions in
order to play the transaction you just
have to make three things which is
created transactions including the
slitting code you would sign it and
finally submit it it is as simple as
that and if you wait a few seconds in
order to wait for instruction to get
mine we can retrieve the contract
address and we can verify that the state
variable
gets initialized with zero I forgot to
mention that the contract we just
deployed what it does is to store state
variable in the blockchain and it gets
updated which every call to alpha
finally if we want to call alpha if we
want to query alpha we would create a
synchronous actions be a following the
three steps we create a transaction with
a credit to alpha we sign it and finally
we submit it we wait for the word from
Oracle compute node to harvest the event
acree alpha and submit final transaction
after a while we can finally verify that
here successfully we have greeting
external data to determine blockchain
well that sounds how sums up our
progress with the Oracle if there is any
question about this or the arc
integration we would be happy to answer
you